qué podría pasar en el caso de juan
orlando hernández y que procedimientos
vendrán
buenas noches maría clara muchísimas
gracias realmente tenemos que ser claros
en este sentido las autoridades verdad
partiendo del fiscal general el señor
merrick garland
presentaron una acusación como el
gobierno de los eeuu o sea estamos
hablando de que los pesos pesados están
detrás de una investigación que lleva
años en la cual ellos de acuerdo a su
investigación tienen como demostrar que
a través de todas estas entidades
organizaciones de narcotráfico
infiltraron al gobierno de honduras
verdad y pues obviamente de la mano de
lo que es el presidente juan orlando
hernández pudieron encontrar una
colaboración para hacer de este pues un
aliado para poder
transportar enormes cantidades de droga
hablando de 500 toneladas verdad que fue
una situación que también manifestó el
fiscal de distrito damian williams y por
lo cual él ahora está enfrentando duros
cargos en este país del norte y si los
pesos pesados de la justicia
estadounidense están detrás de este caso
como usted lo dice porque hernández se
declara no culpable en vez de buscar un
acuerdo
obviamente tenemos que entender algo
miramar y aclara si él llegara a una
condición de aceptar algún tipo de
situación que correspondiera a una
culpabilidad estaría incluso teniendo
que enfrentar la situación de que se
pueda acusar a su esposa verdad como
cómplice acusar a todos sangran ag
político dentro de la gobernanza de ocho
años entonces aquí hay mucha implicación
a él se le está mostrando como gran capo
y mira y esto es una estructura criminal
que no es de una persona no podemos
suponer que con orlando hernández movió
500 toneladas pero imagínate la
estructura o sea las acusaciones y lo
que viene después de esto es
requerimiento de miles de personas
verdad que tuviera un involucramiento y
podemos decir uno de ellos hoy fue
extraditado como una persona que se
acusa de haber colaborado con hernández
verdad y me refiero al ex general de
policía verdad convenido como el tigre
bonilla del señor juan carlos ponía hoy
fue extraditado con ese mismo propósito
usted habla del hermano del exmandatario
tony hernández y lo menciona en la
estructura que tanto le puede jugar esto
en contra al expresidente bueno
realmente creo que el juez kevin castel
tuvo una expresión muy visceral en él en
lo que fue la lectura de la sentencia de
tony hernández al manifestar que ya en
ese momento el nombre de juan orlando
hernández ya no era co conspirador 4 no
eras ese 4 sino que los puso con nombre
y apellido y le dice usted junto a su
hermano el presidente juan orlando
hernández
hicieron para poder traer aquí demasiada
droga y eso daño a la gente en eeuu y
eso es por lo cual usted tiene que pagar
entonces yo creo que esta situación hay
una situación que tony hernández no pudo
actuar en un país donde nunca tuvo ni
una esquela de tráfico sin haber tenido
la protección de su hermano que
recordemos que nunca es un presidente en
la persona más informada y con mayor
inteligencia y que él no lo supiera nos
deja mucho que desear